[Musique]
m
merci de nous rejoindre sur tv soixante
dix huit pour un nouveau numéro de v y
pv rivlin oise personne est aujourd'hui
l'invité c'est isabelle olivier
bienvenu.merci vous est la cofondatrice
dans des actifs basés sur plaisir c'est
un collectif contre les inégalités les
injustices que subissent les familles
touchées par le handicap handicap que
vous connaissez bien puisque vous êtes
sa maman d'une petite fille de 8 ans qui
est atteinte de quadri paresi alors vous
pouvez nous présenter déjà on vous voit
avec votre petite fille justement si une
photo de nos confrères des nouvelles de
versailles la quadri paresys et quel
type de pathologie alors en fait elle
est infirme moteur cérébral un don
qu'elle a eu des lésions à la naissance
dû à un manque d'oxygène et ses lésions
ont provoqué
et de la paralysie au niveau des membres
inférieurs des membres supérieurs et
également au niveau de la parole c'est
pour ça qu'on parle de quadri pas
résident donc sa notion atteinte aussi
bien des membres inférieurs que les
membres supérieurs
donc ça a une incidence au quotidien
vous est présente en permanence avec
elle alors en permanence n'ont depuis
quelques temps puisqu'elle a pu quand
même être scolarisés à actuellement elle
est à lire et à toulouse lautrec de
vaucresson
mais par contre c'est c'est des gestes
quotidiens en permanence quand elle
rentre à la maison puisqu'elle ne mange
pas toute seule qu'elle ne peut pas
faire sa toilette renée s'habiller donc
on met effectivement en permanence en
train de s'occuper d'elle ça veut dire
que vous avez mis personnellement votre
activité professionnelle entre
parenthèses si j'ai réussi à obtenir un
mi temps
heureusement ce qui me permet quand même
de conserver
une activité professionnelle mais le
reste du temps c'est à dire pendant les
vacances scolaires et le soir je
m'occupe d' analyse et on lui fait faire
énormément de rééducation pour lui
permettre d'évoluer d'acquérir le plus
d'autonomie impossible vous venez dire
l'a finalement été scolarisés ça veut
dire que c'est un long parcours avant
d'obtenir une scolarisation alors attend
que ça pour nous on a eu cette chance et
que l a été d'abord dans un premier
temps hospitalisée à l'hôpital de jour à
l'hôpital de garches pendant trois ans
où elle a effectué sa maternelle
mais après il faut effectivement faire
une demande à la mdph pour pouvoir
l'orienter vers un verre un
établissement scolaire
donc nous heureusement on a eu de la
chance qu'elle puisse rentrer dans cette
erea mais c'est pas forcément notre cas
de trop compliqué pour vous néanmoins si
vous avez fondé ce collectif en 2017
c'est aussi pour dénoncer les injustices
au quotidien alors quelles sont ses
seins justice que vous subissez alors
justement pour beaucoup de parents la
scolarité d'un enfant c'est un parcours
du combattant
puisque tous les ans et pour ceux qui
sont les enfants sont scolarisés en
milieu normal tous les ans il faut
renouveler la vsc en fait le parent ne
sait jamais si au mois de septembre il
va avoir une avs ce qui fait que quand
on a une activité professionnelle c'est
pas possible
quand l'avez s est malade il faut être
là pour la remplacer donc c'est
extrêmement lourd est extrêmement
angoissant pour les parents si ce ton de
vie scolaire qui sont difficiles à
obtenir à obtenir
et puis c'est aussi pour certaines
pathologies qui sont un peu plus graves
comme le polyhandicap où là il ya une
atteinte d'une déficience mentale
bien sûr les enfants ne peuvent pas être
scolarité que scolarisés en milieu
normal ce qui fait que les parents sont
sur liste d'attenté pour qu'ils soient
intégrés dans des instituts d'éducation
motrice ou institut louis m
il ya beaucoup de parents qui vous ont
rejoint au sein de ce collectif qui
rencontre ces difficultés alors on est
actuellement 1300 par an c'est énorme
c'est énorme énorme 1300 parents qui
rencontrent ces difficultés 2017 c'est
la date de création du collectif et ce
qui est une évolution depuis positives
ou négatives dans les mesures qui ont
été prises alors dans les mesures
gouvernementales
hélas non pas grand chose parce que 2017
c'était aussi l'élection c'est essentiel
donc lui c'était aussi d'alerter en fait
on a alerté un peu tous les toutous les
candidats aux présidentielles
on s'est aperçu que très peu
connaissaient les difficultés du
handicap
donc on s'est dit c'est pas étonnant
qu'il n'ait pas vraiment de bonnes
politiques d'appliquer jusqu'à
maintenant puisque l'une ya une
méconnaissance de nos difficultés
là je vous avouerai que les familles
d'enfants handicapés sont extrêmement
déçus de la politique actuel notamment
sur celle des aidants familiaux
puisqu'on attend depuis deux ans une
protection une reconnaissance et ce
n'est toujours pas le cas on est
extrêmement déçu après on a quand même
qu contacté de nombreux députés de
nombreux sénateurs on a rencontré madame
le ministre louis handicap
on lui a soumis énormément de
propositions
donc elle a tout en main sauf qu'en fait
on s'est aperçu qu'il n'y avait pas de
budget et quand son budget on peut pas
faire grand chose
aujourd'hui on est dans le cadre du
grand débat enfin legrand terrebasse le
grand débat se termine en tout cas vous
êtes exprimés dans ce cadre là nous on a
envoyé on a écrit on a rédigé un cahier
de doléances qu'on a envoyé donc moi
pour ma part à la mairie de
de plaisir dans d'autres mairies et
localement est également gelé envoyer
aussi à l'association des maires de
france et on l'a envoyé à tous les
députés et bien sûr la totalité des
députés on a eu à peu près 5 réponse
réponse qui vous ont dit soit qu'ils
prenaient en compte nos cahiers de
doléances j'ai reçu entrevoit lequel ont
été reçues ou soit effectivement on a
certaines propositions de rendez vous
mais on était extrêmement déçu on se
rend compte que de toute façon ce sujet
n'intéresse personne et qui n'a pas
vraiment été débattues ces derniers
temps dans le cadre des manifestations
des gilet jaune quand vous vous dites
déçues ça veut dire que vous baissez les
bras
non nous allons terminer toujours
complètement donc de toute façon on aura
l'énergie pour est temps que nos
difficultés seront là on continue à se
battre on continue à essayer d'obtenir
des rendez vous là dernièrement on a
rencontré hamid al ani vidal pardon
qu'il était député qui est en charge de
la concertation nationale pour la perte
d'autonomie pour lui parler du rôle de
l'aidant familial et de ce que le
gouvernement comptait faire
et en fait on s'est aperçu qu'il y avait
eu un recul de la part du gouvernement
sur ce sujet au départ madame cluzel
nous avait promis un statut de l'aidant
statut qui permettrait une
reconnaissance vis-à-vis des employeurs
jusqu il faut savoir qui est à peu près
50 6 % des familles qui ont un enfant
handicapé qui perdent leur emploi à la
suite de l'annoncé du handicap
donc c'est énorme et en fait madame
vidal nous a dit que finalement il n'y
aurait pas de statut comme promis par
madame plus elle mais juste une
reconnaissance sociale parce qu'il n'est
pas du tout la même chose
et en fait elle nous a dit qu'ils
auraient pas non plus deux
de loi spécifique pour les aidants
familiaux de parents d'enfants
handicapés mais que les lois qui serait
voté pour les les personnes âgées en
fait les aidants familiaux de personnes
âgées servirait opère aux parents
d'enfants handicapés
donc en fait ils n'ont pas du tout tenu
en compte pris en compte nos
spécificités des dons familiaux
votre énergie vient d'où petite fille ma
petite fille qui est une battante qui
malgré son handicap à une joie de vivre
en permanence elle est tout le temps en
train de sourire et pour la photo
voilà et puis elle en veut quand on lui
fait faire beaucoup de stages de
rééducation elle est toujours toujours
là toujours envie de progresser toujours
fier de ses progrès donc on peut pas
baisser les bras
c'est impossible c'est la question que
j'allais vous poser aujourd'hui une
progression et on évalue une évolution
comment va-t-elle alors aujourd'hui elle
a fait énormément de progrès au niveau
du langage
il faut voir qu'il ya trois ans elle ne
parlait pas là maintenant elle arriva à
s'exprimer même si elle prononce mal
certains moque parfois on a des
difficultés à la comprendre
du coup on n'a plus besoin de sa
synthèse vocale elle s'exprime librement
elle a fait aussi énormément de progrès
en terme de la marche jusqu'à la rive à
faire quelques pas tout seul sans tomber
bien sûr c'est pas suffisant pour
qu'elle puisse marcher librement mais ça
permet de faire plein de choses le fait
qu'elle soit sur ses pieds si on parle
de l'avenir quelles évolutions possibles
justement elle peut progresser encore
plus et là encore il va là elle a encore
des axes de progression c'est ce que les
kinés nous disais c'est surtout si de
par sa volonté donc donc on espère on va
on essaie de lui donner le maximum de
chances pour qu'elle continue à
progresser jusqu'à ce qu'elles ne
puissent plus en fait c'est tout le
décalage entre cette progression et
cette joie de vivre et les difficultés
que vous rencontrez de l'autre côté des
pouvoirs publics qui ne vous entendent
pas si on revient un petit peu sur sur
les débuts pour savoir un peu plus sur
vous comment vous avez accueilli cette
nouvelle
au moment où vous avez découvert votre
petit free était handicapé comment ça
s'est passé ce mois en fait c'était
c'est les murs de la maison qui
s'effondrait s'étaient tous nos projets
qui s'effondrait en fait on nous a dit
donc on ne savait pas trop où exactement
quand elle est née quel était le
handicap qu'elle allait à voir donc
ils nous ont proposé en fait toutes les
possibilités y compris une déficience
mentale et ce qu'ils nous ont dit
surtout c'est que la seule possibilité
c'est la rééducation
sauf que à l'époque on ne savait pas que
la france nous propose est si peu de
rééducation faut savoir qu'en moyenne on
a fait des enquêtes dans le cadre du
collectif et on s'est aperçu qu'en
moyenne les personnes avaient deux
séances de rééducation par semaine ce
qui est loin d'être suffisant et dans
les autres pays européens notamment ce
n'est pas le cas non en allemagne
notamment
ils ont à peu près 5 à 5 séances de
rééducation par une par semaine
comment peut expliquer ce gouffre entre
certains pays comme européens qui
prennent mieux en compte
ils sont mieux sensibiliser je pense que
le gouvernement met plus de moyens pour
justement aider les enfants et la france
en fait c'est pas c'est une volonté du
gouvernement qui n'est pas là qui n'est
pas présente n'est pas de volonté quel
que soit le pouvoir public quel que soit
le la couleur politique à chaque fois
pour vous écouter on l'a bien compris il
ya beaucoup de soin tout ça doit être
très coûteux aussi en marge de ce
collectif vous avez fondé une
association
oui oui en fait on a fondé une
association d'aidé dès l'âge de 3 ans
d'anaïs puisque on s'est aperçu qu'il
n'y avait pas suffisamment de
rééducation et que à l'étranger on
proposait des méthodes de rééducation
qui n'était pas connue en france sauf
que quand on part à l'étranger pour des
rééducations ça n'est pas pris en charge
par la sécurité sociale donc le seul
moyen de pouvoir accéder à ces
réducation s'est trouvé d'argent
malheureusement pour les pour les
financer il ya une solidarité par contre
la solidarité existe alors effectivement
oui de par notre entourage nos amis et
même des personnes qu'on a rencontré par
la suite on s'est aperçu effectivement
que les français sont plutôt solidaires
quand il s'agit de donner pour le
handicap pour des enfants
alors j'ai une question sur vos actions
on l'a bien compris vous êtes déterminé
vous avez participé avec ce grand débat
en tout cas en vous faisant entendre et
je vous souhaite d'avoir des des retours
surtout ça puis vous aviez aussi mené
une opération de lettres au père noël
tout à sensibiliser également où tout
avait été adressée voilà il y avait à
peu près 80 lettres au père noël qui ont
été envoyées donc il ya deux ans alors
l'équipe de madame cluzel a pris soin de
répondre à chaque à chaque enfant
on a trouvé ça très bien mais en même
temps ce qui était dommage c'est que
elle n'a pas répondu sur le fond des
problèmes et ça on le regrette
énormément et les parents qui ont envoyé
des lettres sont déçus parce que la
politique de l'été qu'a été mise en
place depuis n'a pas répondu aux
doléances qui était dans ces lettres
vous avez d'autres actions prévues de ce
type
une carte de vacances cartes postales de
ça peut être on a fait cet été
les poèmes aussi on a envoyé des poèmes
sur sur le handicap
alors on a eu un petit courrier de
réponse après ça va être au fil du temps
on va voir ce qu'on va faire leur
actuellement on travaille sur le sur la
retraite
donc j'ai pu rencontrer un chargé de
mission qui travaille pour monsieur jean
paul ii la boit je vais expliquer un
petit peu les programmes problématique
des aidants familiaux mais des parents
d'enfants handicapés et pas seulement
des aidants familiaux en perte
d'autonomie puisque c'est pas du tout le
même enjeu c'est les aidants familiaux
d'enfants handicapés le deviennent
bleues de venir à l'âge de 25 ans à
l'âge de 30 ans alors qu'en moyenne les
aidants familiaux en perte d'autonomie
le deviennent à l'âge de 55 ans qu'ils
ont déjà travaillé ils ont déjà leur
retraite qui est plus ou moins assurés
ils sont souvent propriétaires alors que
les aidants familiaux de parents
d'enfants handicapés eux n'ont pas tout
toutes ces choses là et ont besoin
vraiment une retraite qui puisse leur
permettre de vivre décemment
au delà des paroles maintenant vous
attendez des actes on l'a bien compris
merci isabelle olivier donc avec ce
collectif andy actif d'avoir participé à
ce ver récupérer puis on se retrouve
bientôt sur l'antenne de télé 78
[Musique]